this week's videos are sponsored by
hello freshmore on them after the
reaction
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we are going to
watch the latest big movie from Netflix
because we missed out on the bird box
hype and we are not missing out on this
hype train I'm telling you that much cuz
we do not want to be left behind for
Leave the World Behind John are you
ready for the next 2 and 1 half hours so
right couldn't be more ready G are you
ready to get down every single messaging
are you ready to explain the ending to
the audience after we have witnessed it
to break down all of its meanings pair
it to whatever book it's probably based
on and break down that as well I have no
idea what we're about to
watch I have not even seen a trailer but
boy are people talking about it so yeah
let's do it leave a like on this video
subscribe and click that notification
Bell so you don't get left behind of the
reject world when we have something here
you know why the Subscribe buttons for
guys thank you to prepper for helping us
set it down these highlights also full
length Reaction watch along so you sync
up with your own copy of Leave the World
Behind available for our super sexy
rejects those are our patrons and over
there we cover several things
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included all right I am ready to
explain this movie to every
cuz I'm going to nail it I'm going to
nail this watch guys I know what it's
about
[Music]
already spooky meaning like Twilight
Zone Vibes planet
Earth is that something coming to our
planet it's the star that led the wise
men to
Jesus a siren warning us about the
danger
I'm about to show you all how smart I am
I couldn't sleep and it has been such a
hellish year for us as you know oh you
have no idea what you're about to get
into you are just constantly anxious
about your job because of all the budget
cuts so I went online this morning and I
rented us beautiful house out by the
beach budget cuts at business Corp all
of this is going to feel so minimal I
thought I'd get a jump on it look at the
crack crack in the Blue Earth oh yes I
fig if I made the reservation and packed
our bags it would eliminate most of the
reasons to say no where are you escaping
from woman I didn't want to wake the
kids so I haven't packed for them yet
but honestly I think they're going to be
super psyched about this it's an
interesting symmetry to the way they're
shooting all this I'm down for little
vacay especially with the kids it's like
the Sun and the Moon oh look at it
symmetry
again deep when I couldn't fall back
asleep this morning I came over here to
watch the sunrise right right and I saw
all these people starting their day with
such tenacity then you had an
existential crisis make something of
themselves I felt so lucky to be a part
of that oh we get so caught up in the
immediate moment but now this made me
matters wo trippy shot then I remembered
what the world is actually like and I
came to a more accurate
realization like a 70 shot I hate people
I love
her I love her one our faces
faces so true damn dude what the Obama
produced
this so this is going to be
environmental I have an idea for a
motion
picture it's like an eye is watching us
and good catch good catch good
[Music]
catch it's cool you guys can just like
do this
yes I like how chaotic the sound design
is here look at that they're all all in
a car but they're all in their own
world friends Julia Roberts had guest
started in episode of Friends too oh
maybe it's this one on the screen it's
not oh damn it no she was in season two
John please all right fine don't be a
freaking [__] when the camera's pointed
at
us part one of the house is this like a
knock at the cabin kind of movie that's
the vibe I'm
getting one of those w TF movies well
like family goes to Vacation get away
house but it's like I heard it was like
an apocalyptic film spoiler I don't know
what that means Wi-Fi password is a
Nella the owner must be one of those
cyber security guys the kiss look so
happy a
dad the higher you climb the more your
world's going to be turned up upside
down from the reality of the situation
yeah see I get movies what a lovely
composition oh my god with the staircase
and the motion of the camera and her
blocking n that's okay I does know a
ridiculous amount of blue in this movie
yeah is well you know blue symbolizing
you know the normal The Familiar you
know the blue pill if you will is that
the bacon eater oh
let's
go oh get out of there I believe they've
done a movie together before pretty
woman he was Richard Gear that's right
he did a great job playing Richard Gear
let me tell
you they're not mine relax I bought them
I know you like to sneak a smoke here
and there I figured we're on vacation
why not I want you to have a good time
sure it's just just an easy thing to
stop doing
y I got another idea for a good time
time intimacy
maybe oh man's pent up 15 minutes before
they're begging to go to the beach get
to it that's get to
it nice nice guys oh and a and
a interpret it faster joh we're going in
a roundabout Circle in life well and you
know he there was a circular anyway uh
they just engaged in I don't want to say
it God you're making us look so stupid
just enjoy the movie is what some
comments are saying you know a circle is
kind of like a hole
[Music]
and is this going to be an environmental
movie I really don't know I can't tell I
mean maybe although everything's been so
Lush thus far but I like it's like the
music choices they have this like sci-fi
undertones throughout yeah look at that
boat
so big like Noah's sh oh there you go
two of every person on board it's
getting closer oh yeah she's a be looks
like an oil tanker M the thing is that
pollute our Waters
[Music]
uh-oh all these swooping
angles you okay Rose I think that ship
is heading towards us only the kids be
paying attention gen Z is going to fix
it
oh my god oh that is kind of scary
actually that's unsettling
yeah up AR come on bud help us back up
believe it already why that's
why wow
wowe that's a terrifying shot that is
unnerving yeah that really a terrifying
shot white lion Jesu
christe wow oo
buddy
jeez white lion yeah let her Roar onto
that
beach excuse me officer you know what
happened there's been a handful of these
groundings up the coast something to do
with the nav system because we've lost
our way the Wi-Fi isn't working I think
the router needs to reset well sorry I
can't help you there you are the tech
whiz not I you know the TV's out too
this is my worst nightmare by cutting
off cable TV and the beer supply I can
Ure an honest winners work
come here look oh my God slow down
appreciate
life Wow should I get my gun yeah I I
feel like someone's going to shoot them
it's a good omen seen dear at least
according to meso American mythology
damn well red
guy that's the very last episode of
Friends at least they made it to the
finale dude yeah you can die happy now
it don't make it hard and isn't that the
point of my life o Jenga great metaphor
for coll collapsing Society yeah a
precariously assembled apparatus that
can topple at any moment her second book
is like an exploration of how media
serves as both an escape which is a
contradiction that she manages to
reconcile seems like it's kind of what
this movie is doing oh man meta
someone's here get a bat a bat why would
I have a bat because you're in The Purge
yes lock down the house this is
interesting nowadays like a knock at the
door like let me get the bat hello hi
I'm so sorry to bother you in case you
didn't
[Laughter]
know you must be Amanda you must be
Amanda hello Amanda you you two know
each other no we have not had the
pleasure of meet him face to face I'm
I'm GH George he's George that's how it
reads in his email Uncle good Hank see
this is why I much prefer life before
the internet cuz we would have spoken on
the phone you recognize my voice and
knowing that this is our house whoa what
a crazy shot what a divide this is your
house why are you being judgmental about
it I'm sorry you think we could come
inside oh there's a loaded shot for you
how do they do that shot that was
amazing yeah I understand how strange
this must be for you us turning up like
this unannounced we'd have called you
see but uh the phones are out yeah my uh
my phone doesn't seem to have service
it's almost as if we're telling the
truth ouch but yes J agree why are you
guys making this so God damn awkward why
don't we sit down and you know talk and
listen to some Bikini Kill children are
sleeping I wouldn't worry too much about
them I mean Archie sleep through the
atom bomb foreshadowing yes he's on the
board of the philarmonic he likes to
encourage everyone he knows to take an
interest in classical music oh my God
he's this character out of green book
driving back to the city home then
something happen a blackout the lights
here seem to be working pretty good we
have a generator so there was a blackout
and you decided to drive all the way out
here these roads they're familiar I
barely even thought about it so when we
saw the lights go I looked at Ruth and
said that he would feel better if we
stayed here the implication that she's
suspicious cuz he is a black man yeah
this is way too big and nice a house for
him to afford on his own under the
circumstances we we thought you might
understand of course masasa is sukasa as
our casa is sucasa we thought maybe if
you let us stay because again it is like
our
house what she's trying to say is we
wanted to be somewhere safe uhhuh we
could absolutely refund you your money
you want us to leave it's the middle of
the night my my children are sleeping
upstairs you come in here and talk about
refunding our money I I I think I need
to call the company whoa dude chill
we're not saying you should leave we're
saying we should all sleep together yeah
50% of what you paid you know there's an
in-law suite we stay downstairs
downstairs 50% I think we need
50% I am so Ethan Haw in this position I
be like yeah D 50% man yeah I don't feel
comfortable staying in a house with oh
finish that sentence should have
listened to my wife and had these
labeled already yeah you better find the
right one quick
though no that's good it makes you
suspicious like did he take the keys
yeah
oh yeah check off's gun and check off M
they would cue the audience in that
there's a gun there it's really they
break perspective $1,000 an now for the
night that should cover almost half of
what you're paying for the weekend
$1,000 well you you you think they're
lying me it's a young woman and her
father they look innocent enough they're
strangers they introduce
themselves they introduce themselves
what if what if what if the blackout and
and and whatever that's just all part of
the story in the boat going on the beach
what if this was all them what if they
did all this to convince us to let him
stay here he had the keys remember so
what if he had the keys maybe he's the
handyman she's the housekeeper the
housekeeper always knows where the stash
of money is you're saying some of the
most racist [__] without saying without
flat out saying she seen the help okay
she's doing her part something is
happening and I don't trust them
I think they are scared nice people who
need a place to spend whoa is that a
security camera what the hell is this
shot yeah yeah you know I might have a
drink haven't touched this one yet it's
all yours oh thank you all right what's
in it
exactly that is a heck of a cocktail you
should try this babe I think you dig it
I'm about to knock
out I'm drunk
already I think I need some fresh air he
got some interesting tattoos I wonder if
they are hers or if they are for the
movie I like this this like acting
toward to force man everyone's so good
it's such a good Rhythm how long have
you been here bought it almost 20 years
ago now fixed it up about 5 years back
had a great contractor a lot of little
details were his idea whereabouts is
your place in the city we on Park
between 81st and 82nd wow you talk like
a cop where's your wife curious if
you're worried about her in the city my
wife she's on a work trip in Morocco her
flight is due back here in the morning
actually can I see your ID whoa yes left
my wallet in my C- pocket which I
checked at the symphony said you heard
about the blackout while you were on
your way
home
uh this is a National Emergency all
radio stations and televisions will
cease their programs during this is The
Purge yeah you got 12 hours we're only
talking about a blackout here a blackout
is not nothing it could be something be
a symptom of something bigger like
terrorism or a bomb like the one that
you said your son would sleep
through she looks very familiar I think
D you should stay here tonight for $500
more dollars
yes oh no symbolism
symbolism what do we get to do tomorrow
there
laundry wowe that's done nice a shitty
basement I mean yeah what a dump we need
to get them out of here we're not going
to do that by scaring them whoa they
need to think everything's going to be
okay interesting they would cut this
perspective everything is going to be
okay isn't it oh when it comes time to
survival you just got to be with your
own I don't mean that racially be with
your loved ones or chosen family she was
with us don't take it so personal I
don't think I can listen to much more
that snark even if this does turn out to
be their house
well there is not one photo on the wall
not one not a wedding picture of the
supposed art dealer wife on the business
trip or that spoiled brat as a baby
wolof why didn't you say anything about
what we saw at the beach today that boat
was an oil
tanker it's not a boat it's a
yacht oh Cyber attack oh yeah no they
said the naval
radar the Curve the Navy
thingy maybe it's not an apocalyptic
movie yeah still be an apocalyptic thing
maybe it's an AI apocalypse I was
literally about to start the friend
series finale but the internet on my
iPad still isn't working this is why you
should download it is there's something
wrong with the TV it's all messed up
please fix this I have incredible
anxiety about how they're going to wrap
up the
show it's a vacation dad said on
vacation we can have as much screen time
as we want well I did not say that
clay look
look you think those black people
programm this on my
phone I was just there there were four
news alerts two about the blackout and
one that said hackers were behind the
power outage maybe they hack the cell
network is is that a
question I'll go to the store buy a
newspaper find someone who knows more
than we do I will take care of this FR
us his hair looks great still yeah he
got a great Bed Head he going out into
the quiet place whose car is that looks
expensive let's get some breakfast oh
damn it they are rich philarmonic types
dad can you fix it yeah see no it's is
it's not working I'm aware I'm going to
go to the store later and maybe I can
find something that you know help you
get one of those uh some rabbit ears or
something it's like watching a play
yeah 1 2 3 4 5 six there's just enough
chairs for everyone to sit at dude it's
like it was
planned oh my there's more deer than
before they're just waiting to take back
the
Earth you can pet them they won't bite
you or
anything bond with nature you're going
to be totally safe dude if you keep your
feet on the grass for 20 minutes it'll
make you feel like crazy good and
[Music]
stuff
wowe wow you're a weird kid yep maybe
she can communicate with
[Music]
them 96 what does that
mean oh it's radio station John tell me
that about the numbers what is the
symbolism of well they're facing away
from each other and so it it symbolizes
uh a rift in ideology division people
pitted against one another or people
back to back facing out brevity is a
soul witch yeaha hackers mhm where are
the power plants in New York City why
are you asking about power plants cuz
the power went out you remember that
thing that happened in Jersey a few
years back it nearly caused a meltdown
what the hell is she talking about the
thing if it's okay with you I would like
to keep what's going on between the
adults the kids like the pool I'm just
going to encourage them to do that until
we know more I don't want to scare
anyone but I disagree with you disagree
with me about
what I don't think this is nothing what
is it that you do I'm in advertising on
the client side a manage relationship
this little girl takes command of the
scene man where's clay he went to the
store to get a newspaper or try to find
someone to talk to to see if they know
what's going on Kevin Bacon oh yeah
Kevin Bacon thought I'd go over to our
neighbor's house the hugley you often
see no one here around this time but
I'll drive over anyway and check before
you go you might want to hear about the
alerts alerts oh news alerts on my phone
this morning two of them were about the
blackout but then there was one that
said something about maybe hackers were
behind it is he behind it in some way I
don't know trying to figure out what it
means when this camera starts looking
down at everybody I'm sure this will
turn out to be a big nothing like that
love you bug this feels very Twilight
zoning what's a love you bug there's a
computer worm spread throughout the
internet back in 2000 people would get
an email with the subject line that read
I love you if you clicked on the
attachment it would send it to all your
contacts oh cool turns out it was just
two teenagers in the Philippines poo
Pride baby hey I mean still pretty
consequential and what message did that
just send to her I think I'll go Rush
Arie
along I mean he's trying to minimize the
Fear Factor to get them out and she's
trying to scare them into getting out
I'm worried about Mom you think her
flight is going to be okay nah sure
matter of fact I bet she's been
redirected to some airport in Ohio what
a transition through that glass she's
probably cursing out every customer
service rep till they put on a plane all
how do
they yeah these Reflections are wild
were they just in the
house yeah they went out did a really
sneaky pan through the window there and
then they added the glass
back man this over Reliance on
technology dude you're going to crash
into the beach with a GPS like that
you're going to crash into like 47 deer
yeah the hu sleep
send them all as a
text h okay well I believe this really
is his house though at
least I love how there's like the
composed music is in such star
contradiction with its soundtracks
yeah you know hi what are you looking at
get they're just lurking behind the
shrubs oh interesting a dark horse not a
p I need to look up what a deer and a
horse symbolizes
[__] someone in this situation is a bit
of a Dark Horse it's too deep it's too
deep for me now from the ongoing Cyber
attack has led to a catastrophic
environmental disaster in the South
impacting animal Migration pattern 1619
is that a number six and nine keep
coming back yeah I'm like where 1619
where exactly are we in history US
history I will figure you out movie is
challenge I will leave
smart smarter than
you ref reflection Reflections constant
theme
Reflections constantly with the pose of
the upside
down wowe I mean it was just from the
wind some of that stuff that to a throne
there's a breaking definitely a breaking
Arie I saw something this morning dear
there everywh dumbass this was different
like they were trying to tell us
something let's see what else is out
there yeah maybe there's like an army of
hedgehogs hello anyone home it's GH I
let myself in squelch
intensifies
a well if they introduce themselves
they're not a stranger anymore that's
right
hello oh good where have we transition
to with these deep in the heart of the
forest they were just at the pool a
second there just unincorporated land on
the edge of this like pristine
estate oh is he getting like all the
guns together all right okay all right
that was racist John I'm
sorry sat
[Music]
phone satellites are out too there's a
cyber hack we saw at the beginning of
this part two that the satellite was
falling asleep turned a little bit that
means oh my God off he's wearing his
obey shirt dude symbols maybe it's just
where he sleeps though where he hides at
night oh who never made that impression
dude you found Bigfoot's
[Music]
Hut
oh the geography of this is
fascinatingly framed man I love the
music though oh yeah feels kind of
tribal no no I I don't have any service
either I
uh
something red everyone who speaks
Spanish probably knows what the whole
movie is about now I know but just laid
out the entire
movie oh my god dude oh my God step on
the gas pedal
faster oh God the look on his F just
fixed still motionless that language
barrier we can't help we fear the
unknown John that's true God these
window wipes man jeez I know they wasted
so much money on getting these shots
done I'm like this is probably a
surprisingly High CG Budget on this
movie isn't that the room you are
sleeping in
ew the
fudge yep that is an arm on there oh
whoa
awesome my god wow what a crazy shot
dude these locked off shots though W and
I love how it's still at a distance
yeah that's so creepy that is
unnerving saw the watch but didn't see
the dead bodies oh my God these
[Music]
images
oh the plane did crash don't tell me
your wife was on that
[Music]
plane feel like I'm watching Revelations
yeah why are some of these bodies like
naked this morning I saw deer 100 maybe
more right in the backyard if you're so
worried about it why don't you just ask
Mom and Dad no one cares what I say shut
up shut up
Meg oh my God yo people need to stop
going to the beach in this
yeah wao it's like North by
Northwest
wow wow holy go what a shot what a shot
oh your daughter watches that show every
human watches are we are we about to
criticize so much I could take careful
what you say next don't get me wrong I
watched it too it's almost nostalgic for
a time that never existed you know
that's kind of a fair point yeah I'll
give you that it's a fantasy you want to
bet the last line of this movie is going
to be where tell you what I mean by that
later little no bad you got a parasite
now boy it's the ruins feel like we're
watching The Book of Revelations you
going to tell us why you're soaking what
tell them what you saw I fell into the
pool you fell into the pool why why hide
the information you mind going to my
study and getting me something to wear
afraid this is only change of clothes I
had downstairs oh he's going to protect
her from the information I knew
something was coming what do you mean
the Dow was up in my line of work you
have to understand the patterns that
govern the world you have to learn how
to read the curve that's part two the
title it's been as long as I have doing
it it can help you see the future it
holds steady promises Harmony also lates
a lot of money why are you telling me
this did your neighbor say something to
you no he wasn't home he has a satellite
phone I thought could help us it didn't
work even though it had enough juice now
the whole point of a satellite phone is
that you always to have a signal if you
have a clear view of the sky which I did
oh boy only reason why it wouldn't work
is if our satellites got knocked out of
commission spooky don't you think you're
maybe getting a little carried away I
mean maybe you just didn't use the phone
right I saw a plain nose dive out of the
sky into the ocean thank you yeah
D pan over to the guy at the
piano what
the apocalypse just happening around
them
wowe whoa
dude from
W yeah buddy I bet we ain't going to
find out jack [__] about what causes
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just going to
end with them all lined up looking at
something we don't see what it is
whoa the the subtle use of image
stabilizers in this is wild too yeah the
way they mess with the frame rates and
way like like this kind of slow motion
is great yeah great shaky can that's
awesome one it's like the
shake to her footsteps
yes oh
yeah what noise noise noise noise noise
I mean whoever's causing this is
stripping us away from our resources
that we primarily rely on which is all
this electronically should have covered
my ears sooner now my head feels weird
oh was it a um like a a plane breaking
the sound barrier or whatever that
planes don't usually break the sound
barrier the Concord doesn't fly anymore
maybe it was a plane that we don't know
about maybe it was UFOs why don't you go
cuddle up in Mommy's bed and read that
book deck out you read when I have
friends looming over me so when her
daughter watches that season 2 episode
of Friends when Julia Roberts yeah was
seducing CH it's also in the oceans 12
Universe Julia Roberts just exists
independently of all these other women
who look like jul
Roberts since you're the one with the
crystal ball was that a bomb a missile I
don't know anything for certain yet you
seem pretty certain a minute ago with
your haunting
cqu yep fair point we wait for clay to
come back and we see what he's learned
or we should fill the bathtubs full of
water or is there enough batteries and
Tyle and food and straw that makes it
safe to drink dirty water I think we
shouldn't do anything until Klay comes
back what if he's not coming back whoa I
thought she was being sarcastic
yeah tell me what you're thinking
there's the blackout and then you see
the planes crashing and I think Mersa
Le's trying to tell us that we're not
really going to get our answer what
happens next in that sequence everything
I know I have told you I haven't
believed you since you walked through
that front door I wonder what it is
about us that makes you so mistrustful
you know what you're talking about don't
you well ain't that the pot calling the
kettle black roof oh what is she
implying I just couldn't tell you when
if you find out then let me know he knew
at the market in town yesterday there
was a guy in the parking lot he bought
cases of water and canned goods oh yeah
I would love that's Kevin Bacon's only
screen time yeah that's it just the
harbinger and he had 10 slabs apple wood
smoked bacon he a beard guy wearing an
old Cowboy's Hat oh yes he was wearing a
Cowboy's Hat that's Danny he's the
contractor I was telling you about oh is
he the one worked on this house yeah he
made all the cool Deets what happened
did you get to town uh I didn't get far
I you know and then I just started to
drive and then I heard that noise and
and I I came right back does it wipe the
memory still running water I did see
something I it was this huge drone you
know up flying in the middle of nowhere
dropping off thousand sets of these I I
no idea what it says oh
boy oh oh
no God I really got to learn another
language death to America ug no kids
come in handy I don't know what the rest
of this means but but this part it
definitely means death to America I
remember from a game I was playing oh
good was it a Call of Duty I make that
first right this a straight shot to the
expressway with what we know the city
would be the worst place for you to go
we're not going to the city we're going
to my sister's in Jersey Jersey is even
better you have to drive through the
city but to be clear I make a right yeah
it's exactly like how you got here but
listen to me please I love how at first
I wanted to get rid of them yeah and now
he's like no you should stay yeah I I
really appreciate you taking care of us
I do we have to do what's right for our
family oh my
God this is in everyone's best interest
your funeral because you're black
yes you really should have told me what
you saw but I'm certain your mother's
plane wouldn't be flying over over here
it wasn't the same airline that's why he
wasn't saying so okay yeah dude is she
gone I just told you it wasn't even the
same airline yeah but does it feel like
she's gone do you have special ESP
Powers I bet we never get that answer I
would bet that you're
correct Sirens I thought you were
napping honey no I can't why not cuz of
the sirens I don't think it's a
terrorist attack no it's something
greater than
that oh
those look like a lot of the same car a
lot of Teslas up
here this segment of the film was
brought to you part
by the electric cars yeah you can't just
throw electric cars at the problem and
expect them to fix it they just all auto
drove
here self-driving baby we're all brand
new who hey someone's coming in a white
Tesla no one's actually drove the cars
that is selfing oh my God they did all
just drive
here but it has automatic you know
obstruction detection one would hope but
clearly not get right
now oh taking the wheel Julia Take the
Wheel should we flag them down maybe
they know something there's no one in
that car
W Jes shot holy
[__] this is like Elon must wet dream
yeah let's get some cyber trucks in
there wa
who
Jesus at least we know the Teslas work
yes wow you ain't getting in know City
it's like a painting right there that
was gorgeous
shot self that a short chapter yeah it
is biblical the flood cometh one of the
fears of the self-driving car you said
all those cars came off the lot they did
that to every dealership the main roads
are most likely clogged up that is
clever we stay here till we know more if
they are terrorists these are very smart
terrorists we're probably in the middle
of a war zone people we know are likely
dead like your mom m in the plane she
was probably in the plane
Ruth we can't sit here and do nothing we
need to go somewhere he try a in it's
too dangerous he's haunted by the fact
that he let that woman die but is that
all he's haunted
[Music]
by dude she's going to die not having
seen the end of friends filling up the
tub
t not really that's like marijuana they
got different kinds now like fruit
flavors like marijuana
don't mind if I do I always thought of
myself as a sophisticated man someone
who had seen the world for what it was I
have never seen anything like this I
mean okay look I get it Humanity the way
have we have taken over the Earth has
has destroyed so much of how things
naturally work driven animals out of
their take your line of work for example
trying to keep up with this while giving
commentary
same that is most basic my work is and
always has been about people feel real
sorry for you then why is that cuz you
ha people are terrible look at the way I
treated
you and that makes it okay I am sorry
for what I said did thought doesn't
matter some of my smartest clients lost
a lot of money because they base their
choices on preconceived beliefs instead
of truth that's why I always say deals
if you're a black
man
the quiet is so noisy yeah that's a line
found it hard to sleep not like at home
where you hear everything Sirens traffic
people living by the freeway can be
comforting I pull up the sounds of
honking on YouTube to fall
[Laughter]
asleep I am starting to like you I'm
seeing past your skin color and now if
you'll excuse me I'm going top off my
light what yesterday before the symphony
my friend calls me up and wants me to
move around some of his money oh no and
as we're getting off the phone I asked
if he to grab a drink he tells me he's
going away for a while you hanging with
you evil cabal this weekend thought that
was only during the winter
solstice pagans that he doesn't laugh
and he always laughs even with bad
jokes take care yourself almost as if
you felt sorry for me you go ahead and
die are you thinking that you're friend
is somehow behind what's happening here
or he knew he just knew especially when
the truth is much scarier what is the
truth no one is in control yeah he's
just getting out of Dodge no one is
pulling the strings sure there are those
like my friend it's all just collaps in
on itself who might have the right kind
of access to the right kind of
information but when events like this
happen in the world the best even the
most powerful people can hope for is a
heads up
oh yeah it's
Jenga he that is always the push pull
I'm feeling is either either somebody's
deeply in control or nobody is in
control it's the only way these stupid
things can all happen in our world I'm
never going to find out what happens to
Ross and Rachel am I you're still on
this [__] I'll tell you exactly what
happens why do you care so much about
that show anyway they make me happy I
want need that right now don't you if
there's any hope left in this world
we'll at least find out how things turn
out for them I'm sure someone in your
house has seen it the way things are
going you're not going to see that show
ever again so if I were you I'd find
something else to care about Big Brother
of the year I got lost today what do you
mean you got lost I thought I knew where
I was going but then there were all
these streets that didn't have any signs
anywhere you know I turned around and
then I got just completely lost I I have
no idea how I found my way back here to
be
honest but I did see someone uhoh it's
going to confess to her a woman on the
road she waved me down she's speaking
Spanish she needed
help and I left her she have Vaped yeah
truth comes out in the end I really do I
mean even if it is like an invasion an
invasion well or an occupation okay dude
you know what your word choices are like
freaking me the
out oh who who who it's the lady from
the
road
all the
birds migration
flamingos you want to listen to Jazz
sure why not uh cuz I thought we were
going to have some fun Jazz can be fun
now this looks like something a lady can
properly dance to oh come on that's not
what I brought you in here
for I Love This
Thread I wonder if she could tell I'm
hard right now ooo oh my my God it's
like that movie she just did with George
Clooney Julie Robert dances like me they
wanted to get
memed did like that's the key to success
how do we get memd if we can make yeah
get a gift out
there we're drunk we are oh we're
married I'm married you have a wife
shead I really miss her you'll see her
again no
oh no she it was her plane must have
been but if something happened to her
too I don't think I could live it myself
nothing is going to happen to Ruth I
promise she's riding a
flamingo there is no going back to
normal don't say that we have
to
what no not the
screen he's got fever is he okay he's a
little warm but I think he'll be fine I
keep thinking about one westwing episode
there's this story someone tells the
president you watched The West
Wing the story was about a man who lived
by the river in a van down by the river
he hears on the radio that the river is
going to flood the town and everyone
should leave but the man doesn't go
anywhere because knows that God loves
him and will say him but then the flood
actually happens helicopter comes flying
by the pilot lowers a ladder but the man
tells him he isn't going anywhere after
that the man drowns in the flood and so
he goes up to heaven and he's really
angry at God this all happened in the
westwing I pray to you every day I
thought you loved me why didn't you save
me and God says I sent you a radio
report yeah pay attention to the signs
and a helicopter what more do you want
what's this about Rose this situation I
think I'm done waiting I'm I'm going to
find a DVD of friends physical media is
the only way it's just us now isn't it
the [__] goes down do you trust these
people that are in our house a that boy
was sneaking pictures of Me by the pool
that little girl keeps staring into the
woods like Donnie Darko and I'm pretty
sure the husband wants to me hell yeah
he's not actually going to do anything
he's not that guy but did he want to
Absol lutely my point remains I don't
trust them Discerning jeez I'm not going
to let anything happen to you if that's
what you're asking she's so observant
I'm asking for you to remember that if
the World falls apart trust should not
be DED out easily to anyone especially
white people fair just what exactly was
the point of letting them back into the
house was the right thing to do and that
right there what going to in the end
yeah oh stri that's cool you're watching
like the process of what leads to the
survival instincts in an apocalypse you
know totally normally you kind of just
skip to and this is like what Humanity
has come you're watching In This Very
isolated situation the evolution of it
where's Rosie I don't know she got up
before us I'm going to go look around
she get up she's going to check all the
neighboring houses for DVDs oh you're
not so warm
now really cold does your throat hurt oh
no good oh he's a zombie his leg's
falling
off what the is that
blood I don't want what what
is
happening what are you doing oh my God e
glue it back in like the flash why are
you so casual about this oh God ew ew ew
ew e ew God with the roots my teeth yeah
something's wrong with Archie what is it
oh the exactly what I said uh my my my
teeth just they feel weird and I and I
oh
know
not okay not okay not
okay one wait were we in a part four
already I guess we were what was part
four uh the the water oh yeah I right
part three was short yeah yeah that's
right a bug bit me yesterday in the
woods that must be it then probably just
a tick lime disease I've seen stranger
symptoms Stranger Than This and we need
to go to the hospital there ain't no
hospital the expressway is the only way
out of town besides if the road are jam
don't want to be there to help us anyway
well we have to do something Archie
needs to see a
doctor put your hands on her I'm telling
you I have looked everywhere and she's
not
here she's not down there she behind the
painting she wasn't outside but I think
she may have taken one of the bikes from
the garage a blockbuster she she saw
some deer and she wanted to go look for
them so maybe there I don't know I'm
going wor St to cover your ankles oh my
God I'm coming with you no it's not safe
you cannot leave me here by myself he's
sick Bo don't you see that Dad you will
never come back a set a timer 1 hour
I'll be back actually doing it too
that's good I'll be back for you before
this goes off oh
boy that means we have exactly one hour
left in this movie oh Jesus a long
movie I was so into it until you told me
I was damn got to watch more of this now
[__]
hour this is it's got
yeah swirl to it almost it's like a
spiral it's like Uzumaki but what does
it
mean I want to know what the is the plan
I want to know that we can find my kid
and then get in youring expensive car
and drive to an actual hospital and then
we can just all go back to our house
yeah well what if that's not possible
yeah you don't care that I'm here and my
mom is probably at the bottom of some
ocean I don't have anyone else I have
nothing to go home to but them do you do
you understand that a I care I do I
don't know what I'm supposed to do about
that but I do care Huggers some what do
you get out of being so angry all the
time protection from her actual feelings
no people just suck and she gets to stay
away from them my whole job is to
understand people well enough so that I
know how to lie to them so I can sell
them things they don't really want cool
when you really see the way they treat
each other well you see what they do and
they do it without even thinking about
it you have to kind of just see the wors
in people I think deep down we know
we're not fooling anyone deep down no
it's pretty obvious and agreed upon mass
delusion to help us ignore and keep
ignoring how awful we really are
absolutely I completely agree with the
sentiment here here that's why I buy
beyond
meat fixing the
problem oh whoa the
deer she Now commands the deer yes she's
going to come out riding
them sorry to bother you at home like
this I'm going to need you and your
comrade to step off the porch and stand
by your vehicle your comrade off the
porch and buy your vehicle man Kevin
Bacon and Julia Roberts used to be such
nice bading actors now they're playing
[__] racists what can I do for you
just checking on you if you heard
anything about what's going on yeah I'm
clay my family ran at gh's George just
at home we're from the city oh no well
we came out here because my son needs
help uh he's vomiting he's he's lost his
teeth and they just fell out can't
explain it thank you well it's got to
have something to do with that noise you
know something about the noise it's not
all that the similar to what happened in
Cuba while back microwave weapons they
call it produces a kind of radiation
that can be beamed out through sound
what something is a foot now what that
is exactly I don't know maybe this is as
much as we're ever going to know maybe
we just need need to sit tight pray
whatever works for you I'm going to
watch the Cowboys like clay said his son
isn't well we're going to need more than
just prayers knowing how primed you are
for these kind of situations we're
thinking you might have some medicine
that'll be able to help you what I got
isn't your business
survivalism you telling this man not to
take care of his son nothing makes a
whole lot of sense right now when the
world doesn't make any sense I can still
do what's rational which is protect my
own yeah that's what I was saying
earlier you got to stick to your own of
course and I meant not as a racist thing
yeah yeah
my son's really sick he needs your help
he's 16 years old dude Ethan Hawk is
such a good actor oh dude he's he's
probably my favorite actor now like he
can like do any role yeah I love E's the
hawk you're in a difficult position I
get it I would do anything I had to for
my family so that's what I'm doing yeah
but you were prepared man come on Danny
you can't desert us like this haven't
you been picking up watch me we've all
been deserted everyone's being
deserted make her Your
[Music]
Leader
what I would like all of you off of my
property oh boy we're not going anywhere
till you give us what we
need oh my God he's going to shoot you
dude this guy's been waiting for an
excuse to shoot
[Music]
somebody oh [__] that's right Put the
gun down all right we'll find another
way to the hospital there is no other
way besides he's not going to shoot us
uh sounds like he's going to shoot
us what is going on they just want to
scare him away but also like I would not
resort to this hold on I get out of the
way I'm trying to reason with him he's
white I can talk to him in white people
terms all the roads are blocked we're in
the middle of God knows where there's no
one else around I have no idea idea what
I am supposed to do it's kind of the
point I am a useless man and that is the
point of the
movie what would you do if it was your
family that's what I'm doing it's the
only thing I can do just kill them Kevin
Bacon please help my
son they did it it was them for sure yep
definitely th% it just takes enough
screaming I'm your mom now yeah
seriously bonding
experience he took the
money oh my God this guy Jesus Christ he
took the
money God oldfashioned barter system was
to be expected at some point wow dog hey
I got another tidbit for you free of
charge if you want it it's a Koreans
behind all this who makes you say that
just trust me the Chinese one of them oh
God right underneath the right
underneath the whole Glory
baby the Chinese one of them you know
what those Asian countries they're all
the same big drone dropping these
everywhere it means death to America so
we're thinking Iranians I remember
hearing something on NPR once about
their cyber capabilities pledge Drive
baby NPR before the phones went out I
heard from a friend of mine in San Diego
about a similar event drones dropping
pamphlets except they were in Korea or
Mand any like I said he couldn't tell
which seeing as he did four tours in
Iraq he sure as sure would have known if
it looked like that we made a lot of
enemies around the world maybe all this
means is a few of them teamed up ah cool
we've created Unity yeah the we were
here to do
all everyone United against us we're the
coach of the world Man United States
have United all the other
countries
that house that's got to be where she
went oh she sees Rosy's body I don't
know but she was looking at that house
earlier no matter how far this thing
goes I need to know that we're good cuz
if what just happened here is happening
everywhere we need to get to that bunker
Danny told us about and we need to get
there now what are you talking about
he's saying that you need to team up and
survive together had a sneaking
suspicion but I wanted more information
first all SIDS were there sure but
I whole movie holding out on his man
it would have made more sense if we were
on the brink of an allout invasion but
this I didn't think we'd actually let
something like this happen I thought we
were smarter than that n no there's not
that much order in the world cuz my
primary client works in the defense
sector I spent a lot of time studying
the cost benefit analysis of military
campaigns go there was one program in
particular that terrified my client the
most three-stage maneuver that could
tople a country's government from within
dialogue they give him first stage was
isolation disable their communication
and transportation ation make the target
as deaf dumb and paralyzed as possible
that's us yep setting them up for the
second stage synchronized chaos
terrorize them with covert attacks and
misinformation yep without a clear enemy
or motive people would start turning on
each other that just happened hey we're
all a part of it done successfully third
stage would happen on its own Civil
War
oh War that's what I just no you guessed
that I just heard in my head you thought
C and I said soil War s this program was
considered the most coste effective way
to destabilize the country because if
the target nation was dysfunctional
enough it would in essence do the work
for
you America is doing it on itself yeah
cuz we're just that
dysfunctional can't agree about [__]
whoever started this wants us to finish
it so you're like purging Society yep
essentially you know forced upon you
from the outside 1 hour
pedal to the floor my
dude oh is the house over there the same
one with the Panic
Room the one you said he'd sleep
[Music]
through
cool thought this movie would hold out
on us show this in some like [__]
news
report yeah everything was returned
swiftly to normal after some random
technical
glitch
I bet these guys own all 10 seasons of
Friends in a special Blu-ray collector's
pack yeah what do the Thorns
have let's go she broken glass means
nothing to this
[Music]
camera oh my God you're just in here
having the best
time straight
chilling this is like buddy the elf's
greatest dream
this is what paid for this entire mov
here all the products on this
table I have the set engraving for
poptarts and Reese's and Ocean
Spray wow good
touch oh I would love to build one of
these oh my God the Thorns got it hooked
up oh my God they got jugs of ant Jima
they don't make ant Jima no more one
problem with these basement you know
apocalyptic ones they're always
gross whoa
hey elevator radiation levels where are
these reports coming
from just going to get friends oh my God
they have
friends puffy come on find the DVD
byebye birdie Center
Stage they like
tab Gilmore
Girls friends frays it's
alphabetized got at the final episode
she found a DVD physical media this the
real message of the movie is buy all
your favorite films on DVD or shows
weird message
Netflix this is just one long ad for
them bringing DVDs back to Netflix and
then they scratched the DVD for anyone
who hasn't finished friends is a real
bummer about to spoil the whole show for
a you
know
please end right
here please end right here please tell
me they did it tell me they did it yes
yes I love
it and that was the name of the Final
Chapter right chapter five was called
the the final one or the last one I
think so wow damn killing
it well Rachel got off the plane
oh just spoil it for everyone I got off
the plane I mean I figured the whole
movie Out can't believe I did it you did
it dude you should write movies like
this for Netflix where you'll get paid
and residuals and all that other good
stuff now but you know when you are
dealing with an apocalypse like this
yeah sometimes it's scared to go outside
yeah having to forage for food and
things yeah sometimes you just want that
food delivered fresh to your doorstep
yeah in a way you could stockpile and
hold on to for any occasion no matter
how simple nor world
rending we have to interrupt this
broadcast with a special message from
myself Aloha reject Nation Greg here so
many of you guys know most of my days
are a couple of hours of filming and
then most of the time it's dedicated to
like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often accumulating to like
10 to 12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and and getting healthier
has been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimony and that is of course
for hello fresh and hellofresh is in
just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hellofresh I'm looking
forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to
Healthy Lifestyles best part the variety
it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like
Dijon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and from my more
plant-based days the vegan Maple carrot
power bowls they aren't just meals
they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while
cooking and that's where helloof Fresh's
15minute meals are a life saver they're
quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect
for my non-stop lifestyle so why not
join me in making this holiday season
both health conscious and delicious with
hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every
week there's always something new to try
and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com reject free and use
code reject free for free breakfast for
life is that accurate that sounds way
too good to be true there's no way that
can be true go to hellofresh.com reex
free and use code rejects free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box as long as your subscription is
active tag your hellofresh creations
with # hellofresh piic and at hellofresh
and let's cook up some fun and
healthiness reject Nation remember it's
America's number one meit all right
thank you hello fresh John before we
talk about anything let's create some
categories here o chapters just like in
the movie yeah yeah I want to make sure
we talk about every okay so let's go
over the ending okay and then uh what
what else do we have to interpret or do
should we try to find meaning of uh okay
so just what was really going on yeah
what is this
apocalypse what other things happen that
we should dissect the meaning of animals
Animal symbolism yes definitely oh God
it's going to be hard what else we got
uh we got color symbolism jeez racial
subtext oh yeah man this is going to be
a tough one
damn you know class
commentary and uh go performances
performances tone Direction and
cinematography yeah yeah okay all right
let's go with the ending one first
ending ending explained yes watch us do
this without any research just just
absorbing what the movie's giving us
uhhuh we can do this ending explain all
right so Rosie goes down to the rich
man's bunker uh and then finds the
friend's DVD watches the last one I
think there's multiple meanings here
guys get ready for this Greg's about to
sound so smart smart Greg incoming
Rachel got off the plane I think the
wife got off the plane okay I think wife
survived that's it's a simp yes it's an
Easter egg of sorts it's it's just such
a weird ending to end on her getting the
DVD cuz there's so much emphasis on
it okay let's try to be sincere for one
second John there is this like there is
this emphasis on uh when they find Joy
through certain forms of escapism right
and she I mean the daughter has this
whole thing about like world sucks but I
like these friends people and it's the
way a lot of us describe the show
Friends my favorite show of all time and
I would describe very similar experience
that this this girl uh describes friends
being as then even when um MERS Ali and
Julia Roberts they're dancing it's via
through the form of art through the
music you know so I think that even in
despite these chaotic toerist times that
they are living in uh to put it lightly
that their source of Happiness can still
be found in some form
of
art yeah I would say I think that's
maybe what the the the choice to end on
that specific note ultimately is about
like she finds a genuine smile in that
yeah in that heartbeat of a moment you
know and uh like she pigging out
enjoying the junk food so and but beyond
that I think with ending on
friends which is an art
firm trying to see this like a third
time where they find Art like I like how
is the music in that is there another
moment well I mean there are other
things like she says that like oh they
love the pool I just want them to focus
on that then it's like forms of
recreation and like simple little things
it's a record it's dancing it's swimming
it's being outside it's finding your
favorite show or whatever it might be
and yeah it's those little thing it's
like in a situation that is like asking
you to find impossible solutions to what
seems like the most insurmountable set
of circumstances it's the simple
things whether it's a world rending
scenario or just personally intense
Stakes it's the little things that give
us respit from that that's a very solid
point I think we have explained the
ending indeed friends communal what have
we got here friends people who have
become friends even though at first they
were just strangers to each other that's
true and they're all kind of you know
inhabiting the same building like in
friends they don't you know sleep in the
same room but they're neighbors kind of
if you make the house an apartment
building yeah you know what I mean and
then uh you know rich friends and then
uh uh uh Kevin Bacon is Gunther you know
he's down the road at the cafe fair
enough he gives there were six people at
this home six members ofs I think the
show Friends has way more to do with it
than people realize it does it does I
think you're correct about that and then
for a show that was often criticized for
being just only like white folk yeah got
a little bit more diversity here that's
right this was diverse friends this was
diverse friends is what we watched I'll
be there for you have that song playing
over it when the question posed at the
very end with mersy and Ethan Hawk was
will you be there for me will we be
there for each other when all this [__]
is truly hitting the fan yeah and are
you on the level with me can I trust you
will you be my friend that's that's what
I yep yeah it's beautiful man that was
good saying that's probably what it's
about right I think we have explained
the ending and so and you hear Julie
Robert's voice outside who was on
Friends emphasize this enough yes we
hear her voice as uh as young uh Rose is
sitting down to watch the show so we can
assume that she's going to be found by
her mother and that they probably all
will hold up in this Panic Room for as
long as the resources can go around I
think they I know that we didn't get to
where they find her but they see they
see where the house is it is their house
the timer is set they are going back
they say that they need to go to the
bunker I think it's safe to assume that
they will they all end up bunker down
there together and then fight over what
we watch on TV okay what was the name of
the people who were there in the house
the ho the Thorns the Thorns yeah where
were where were they I don't know they
got out of Dodge maybe we we're not
explaining it see that's the thing is
maybe because they were Rich enough to
already have this off the books Panic
Room maybe they had Panic Room
underneath the yes or maybe they went
someplace else even more secure they
have like a private island someplace and
they got out early cuz like you know
maybe they gave Kevin Bacon a a heads up
you know because he was like Hey you
know here's a little piece of
information for free your friends the
Thorns why don't you go check them out
huh so do you think Mahaw Ali was right
we're moving on in that category uh
right about which thing about him saying
he was breaking it down for Ethan Hawk
uh gotcha gotcha of saying like this is
what's really going on this three-step
thing you know and the implication is
that the United States is doing it unto
itself or we are being attacked and this
is this is their plan well no the
message I took from it is is if we
follow these steps we cut everybody off
from everything and then we create you
know uh simultaneous chaos everywhere
then the people this divided nation of
people will will take care of the rest
Naturally by you know destroying and
eating each other basically perfect I
love to hear you're so pent up here in
the here in these divided states that uh
yeah they'll just we'll take ourselves
down you know all they got to do is
introduce a little chaos and then you
know the misinformation the Lea flits
all that stuff give us a million
directions of where to point the finger
and then you know pretty soon yeah we'll
just all be Scavenging and and looting
and all that stuff wow wow and you
believe that's what was really going on
I believe it he seems convinced it seems
convincing and it also doesn't seem like
it it's both to me it's like I think
logically speaking yeah it is some kind
of you know uh tech-based attack because
of course that that seems like a very
Salient message we rely so heavily on
these interconnected things that we
don't fully understand the nature of
that if we were to be removed from them
we would be many of us quite helpless
and uh and so yeah it's like that seems
like a very conscientious way to take
down you know a country or whatever it
is and you see the bombs going off so it
seemed relatively reasonable to assume
that that what he is saying is happening
is probably the case however you'll
never know or you until it's over in a
situation like this I imagine you
wouldn't really know and so I think yeah
that that little piece of ambiguity
suits it but it does certainly seem like
that three-step scenario he was talking
about yeah I mean a lot of the themes
also seem to about dealing with reality
of the situation yeah even right down to
it's probably on the reac highlights and
I'm going to watch my words here even
right down to um the teen boy in the
midst of everything is still like oh I'm
going to go look at my phone and try to
touch myself a lurk on this girl here
yeah yeah like but he can't ultimately
uh continue to do so um and so but again
and you know like even while they're
dealing with stuff and they're drinking
and and vaping and whatever that they're
they still try to find like forms of
escap is and when so much of this is
about trying to face face reality deal
with reality the cigarette The Vape all
those things yeah man so um that's one
one theme oh man this movie is so
multi-layered it's it's it's it's got
you know it's got some layers it's based
on a book is it I assume so uh didn't it
say it was based on a book it was
adapted or something there was some like
line at the beginning yeah adapter for
the screen or something like that there
was some some text there that implied
based on something yeah uh okay so we
have that themes that's some good themes
yeah well and yeah and at what point do
you accept that the I I think that was a
good theme that they brought up the idea
of like oh is there a shadowy cabal of
people who run the world or is the
scarier alternative that no one's in
control and all these things all these
tenuous agreements we make collectively
that form Society are that are ten
and can be rattled at any
moment animals animals yes well for me I
was thinking about I mean I've tried
saying it but I would get so caught up
in oh my God I feel like there's
important lines happening here yes so I
need to kind of talk while also try to
absorb lines to me brings it back to the
uh roots of Earth for us sure like when
you when you think about like the land
of animal there like this should be a
planet that is
an humans are just another part of the
animal kingdom but we have created this
distinction between humans and animals
yeah and through this distinction we
have created metropolises and technology
and all these things that have slowly
corrupted and destroyed our Earth in
turn destroying the land of our um our
uh our neighbors animals and that's at
least what I was taking from it that was
my interpretation of why there was all
this emphasis on animals and messing
with migration and stuff like that um so
yeah I don't quite get what deer means I
don't understand I don't know the actual
Association of like what does what does
horse symbolism mean what does deer mean
let's do some deer symbolism deer
symbolism in many cultures the deer is a
symbol of Spiritual
Authority during the deer's life antlers
fall off and grow again and uh the
animal is also a symbol of regeneration
and Christian imagination the deer is a
symbol of piety devotion and of God
taking care of explain to me what it
means in the context of this movie John
well all the deer and that is one of the
more overtly Supernatural feeling
elements of this movie that does flirt
with that tone I guess to me it's
perhaps the animals sort of uh maybe
recognizing like Hey we're already out
here we're away from the city we're in
much more of Nature's Domain than man's
domain even though you have this fancy
house here maybe they are recognizing
like hey you're kind of being returned
to our community in a sense we are sort
of here to recognize you and I feel like
the daughter both of the daughters are
the ones they seem to most communicate
to so maybe there's like a a mother
nature thing both of the daughters
though they have very different Vibes
and functions within the story seem
aware of and kind of attune to things in
a way that other characters aren't or it
seems like they're at least not trying
to delude themselves the way other
characters are so maybe it is that they
have that direct link to the fauna
around uh you know in some kind of
spiritual kind of sense I mean that is
that is the point at which the movie
does get the most sort of abstracted and
and you go like okay is this this must
really be happening given how this movie
has presented itself thus far so there
must be like a hundred of deer here uh
so that part of it is is interesting to
me I'd be curious to hear about people's
interpretation of how overt that symbol
is used but you also have the flamingos
you know which uh which I don't know if
there is a direct Flamingo symbolism I'm
way ahead of you there oh what you got
what you got symbol of beauty Grace and
a sense of otherworldliness the presence
of flamingos in the story serves as a
contrast to the chaotic and unsettling
events that occur they represent a
connection in nature what I've been
getting at here a reminder of the
Tranquil world that exists beyond the
chaos of human existence again bringing
us back stripping us away from these
man-made Creations yeah they're just
here going all I really that's what
every animal sort of means here in some
sense I mean yeah especially the more
unless you're in a story that is very
removed from the trappings of modern
life especially modern Western life uh
yeah feel like there's always a little
sprinkle of Spanish speaking woman uh
well I mean that'll be another thing is
is our I I guess that's a heightened uh
version of our inability to communicate
in a crisis scenario and you can't help
but imagine maybe if Ethan Hawk had kept
his head H you know he could have been
the person we all hope to be not just
the person that we think we would be
given the kind of attitude his character
displays much of the time and lead up to
that you would expect him to be the guy
to be like get in and we'll figure this
out but at the same time he's getting
overwhelmed she's I I would love that
one of those things where I was sitting
there going man like a Spanish speaker
in the audience probably has like a
little nugga of context the rest of us
don't and uh and I think that's cool I
think that that at least yeah zero in on
the fact that a chaos situation like
this there will be yes literal language
barriers but in the more figurative
sense there will just be communication
breakdowns when everyone is in a panic
and people are going to handle that
situation sloppily that's part of the
Controlled Chaos that they are
introducing here I guess it's also the
start of like the fear of the unknown
yeah mhm yeah exactly and I mean it it
height it zeros in on some of that
xenophobia certainly not in the most
doesn't exist in this movie not in the
most malicious way but in a way and and
what fear does to you and I mean too
yeah like uh I don't know there's this
was from an earlier point but there is a
certain amount of bargaining I feel like
everybody in this movie does where
they're like no no no there's somebody
out there like someone's going to take
care of his there is an order there's a
hospital we can get to and it's you know
everybody is sort of getting how far
does things need to progress before you
get to the point where you're like well
all we have is what we have right here
in front of us you know yeah yeah movie
kind of hits the nose on hits the nail
on the nose head hits the head on the
nose nail when it comes to you know the
stuff like the electric
cars and um no they're saving the world
me one you got with the Tesla
billionaires um it's okay it'll be rivan
in a few years from now but but I think
it's I think it actually spoke more to
the point
of I just love how it was like the
automated version of the electric car
well and that's a slight leap because I
don't think cars do that yet they they
they test that technology and that's not
been implemented yet for my
understanding because it uh like fully
self-driving no driver intervention or
no driver intermediary just like fullon
no they usually need to I mean they I'm
sure they can uh but in order for them
to usually operate you need a human body
in the driver seat in order to do it
yeah because there are just certain
things but I'm sure they can program it
where they don't need a body in there
well they're they're doing it now and
the reason it's not been made consumer
is because they haven't been able to
fully rectify the machine's inability to
account for certain anomalies so it will
still hit stuff so part of me is like
okay this is a bit of a fantasy because
they're not just selling Teslas that
self-drive but I mean it is the exact
fear you have about those aside from it
just malfunctioning somebody like
maliciously using them to jam up all the
roads is like diabolical everything
crashing in on itself and that sequence
was so was very intense very intense and
also with um yeah like when Julia
Roberts is spouting about of like how we
do these things thinking we're making a
difference when we're not and that is us
in a nutshell and I was I was just
listening to um John
Oliver's uh um segment about chocolate
oh and I had no idea just the amount
of child labor that goes into the
production of our chocolate industry and
yeah that was quite eye openening I've
been very blind to this and I I love
chocolate
so I was like let me buy as much
chocolate as I can before I finish this
video before my guilt kicks in and I
stop buying chocolate any well I have a
year supply of chocolate it would just
be a waste a waste now so I should at
least starving kids who would love to
have that chocolate I should at least
finish this chocolate you should or else
those poor people they're their hard
work will go to away yes you don't want
to spit in the face of all that hard
work
cuz they just get compensated with the
joy of knowing that you're enjoying the
chocolate make me question myself though
like oh maybe I shouldn't buy chocolate
anymore holy [__] I have to only buy
very specific ethical and probably quite
price but even to that point though it
guys get to a point where even they
there's only so much even for the most
ethical of companies there's only so
much mandating they can do to ensure
that like the way how through the
process of this to this to travel to
this that their chocolate is of the
purest non child laboring chocolate you
they they've even had it covers that
like they even they've had to there's
only so much they can do to ensure for
the most ethical ones uh and and so my
point being is that with what this movie
is talking about you know that what
perhaps what we think we're doing as the
real contribution to change is is truly
not enough that the impending doom of it
all because there's their
environmentalism talks here uh I think
this whole thing of world decaying in on
itself is very much an environmental
allegory in a lot of ways there's a lot
of different things they're talking
about but at the end of day it keeps
coming back to like it starts off with
our character of Julie Roberts who is
essentially our main character saying
she hates people but in the end of it
all when everything's stripped down we
will need to rely on each other the the
few who we can trust yeah cuz that's all
you have either way as people yeah yeah
and that is kind of like the nebulus of
humanity I think it was Darwin oh could
be wrong here careful but I'm going to
say it it's up to you if you want to
research it I don't want your Pagan
theories that there are things about um
I remember the meaning at least is that
uh it Humanity has thrived through
cooperation that's how we Thrive so when
you strip us down to our Bare Bones that
love is kind of in our DNA of
cooperation that's a love sentiment yeah
it's a bunch of [__] I don't like it
at all [__] not in the real world not
out here in the Mean Streets not when
the chips are down and everyone's
desperate um and let's talk about
performances um I loved I loved it I
love I mean it was like watching a play
yes I love Julia Roberts's work here
it's been a while since I've SE like I
saw her in ticket to Paradise with
George Clooney and much as I love
watching my old celebrities fall in love
what uh you didn't love the movie I
liked it a lot okay all right I do I
like I like romcoms I liked it a lot
good
um for anyone who doesn't know I I watch
a lot of romcoms it's like I don't ever
react to them but I'll go through my pH
where I'm like watching nothing moram
comes and and I love that I quite
enjoyed it it was a lot of fun it was a
little different too and and uh what's
wrong it hit me finally hit me where I
recognized the actor plays Ruth she's on
that episode of Black Mirror she's the
second episode yeah the documentary one
yeah yeah there you go yeah Netflix keep
it in house don't pay residuals right
that's how we do it we stable of actors
we don't have to pay much and there you
go always ways this is kind of a Black
Mirror esque episode very much um and uh
yeah so I think Julia Roberts was
excellent here showed the most
growth yeah and a character that that is
not the most glamorous to take on but
requires a lot of subtle chops from an
actor yeah yeah she was excellent her
and Ethan Hawk I really believed as a
couple I think Ethan Hawk is absolutely
excellent he's a fire in every role the
guy ever does yeah no matter what genre
he really is like a chameleon he's
special he's he's a true true Talent
yeah cuz he's just so he just seems so
natural in any role he slips into yeah
and even here is like he's not the tough
one in the relationship ship oh that
whole useless man speech broke my heart
and I was like yeah that's a lot of us
yeah yeah that's me all the time yeah
it's like I don't know and and early on
he even says that thing he like your
mom's the tech whiz you know I'm just a
thing he's just a thinker guy yeah loved
his work Mersa Ali commands as usual
sure yeah um I do love the dire it smart
it was smart of the movie to not to
create an immediate plot of like a
horrible of like a terrifying Airbnb
situation gone wrong right yeah get
barbarian with us get barbarian make you
suspicious of like what's really at play
here is it going to be about these
people caving in on themselves as the
movie does lose sight of it's like a
mediate plot and become all about what's
going on in the world and commentary
like it does not in the last like hour
it does just become about that it's all
symbolism and topics I guess we're all
who we say we are there's chaos
happening all around I did kind of wish
the movie focus in a little bit on how
do you keep it about what's really going
on between the people in the house yeah
and that plot and then letting the
commentary also coincide with that
versus let's really just make it about
what's going on out here yeah and Fun
Stuff um so yeah that was one part of it
but the performan has remained as strong
as ever from beginning and like everyone
had chemistry the children writing
children I I think writing a like uh I
don't like to criticize a child's
performance and B I don't uh I I I often
fluctuate on a criticism of writing
children because I I don't ever go
that's not how children talk because I
don't know children and and I don't work
with children so I don't really know
like I think about how children now
as opposed to when we grew up uh they
grow up with cell phones and iPads that
give them access to um all kinds of
media that would that might make their
the way they speak and their vernacular
and all that be much more um more
advanced wide ranging than how when how
I grew up because of the amount of
exposure they have that I some people
think it limits one's capacity to learn
but at the same time it could also
enhance one's language just due to the
amount of exposure they have you know it
makes a lot of things more second nature
and it is interesting because we live in
a time where you know you have the idea
in your mind from my you know from our
perspective I'm sure of like movies
where kids talk like adults and it's a
Trope and it's and it's a precocious
child yeah but we also now live in a
moment where kids or at least younger
and younger kids are able to speak with
more and more adult inflection and
vocabulary because of the vastness of
the internet they have access to and
like yeah yeah I think you you said
something during the movie which I think
is true it's like you know it's hard to
write kids partly because you're
probably drawing from kid talk from when
you were a kid which was probably a
while ago and now we live in a time
where more so I think than ever before
just again because of what the
advancement of the internet and every
kid having an iPad or an iPhone is like
yeah there is a different it's not the
same as precocious child of yesterday
year but it is like a different tonality
of of characterization I guess and it is
hard to nail down certainly and I mean
between the two I I think I preferred
Rose to the brother prefer the character
yes yeah I thought
the we hear
audio doesn't matter doesn't matter
doesn't matter as long it's not on the
video um so yeah I I think the the teen
boy god what the hell is his
name it's definitely coming from in the
computer though what is this what is
happening right now
yeah it's come from in the computer
where is it we're so late in the video
it's on this confusion is happening
what's going on out there John running
it can't
be
uh I'm it doesn't make any sense I'm
just going to close out all of our web
Windows just close it all out shut it
down all right I mean there's only so
many things I can shut down now shut it
shut it all down something's playing on
a loop it's Coy's voice from some other
earlier recording and I don't like it I
don't like to hear it nope I don't like
to hear a vager even if it's not in our
our little record even if it's not our
headphones there's a tiny bit I don't
like any of it John it's bothering me
it's gone it's bothering all right cool
let's just keep talking we're fine it's
gone we're fine um so teen boy like
while like very much no depth at all to
that character no not even like an
attempt at depth anti-de depth yeah he's
just that typical teenage he's a horny
teenager and like what else is there to
and my sister's a drag and I'm going to
do everything I can to not open up to
her yeah yeah
uh I didn't really care for him uh but I
weirdly found the writing on him more
believable just because of the cliche of
a teenage boy and I know what it's like
to be a teenage boy so even though I
didn't behave like that when I was a
teenage boy I know known enough teenage
boys when I was teenager to get that and
uh and her like that that was my point
of of of like I can't sit here and tell
you that little girl wasn't believable
because I don't know what it's hard for
me to wrap my head around finding this
little girl believable even though I'm
sure there are little girls out there
who are just as like hyper intelligent
and precarious and
thought-provoking but I still liked her
character enough um to enjoy when she
was on screen the rose character the the
young young one yeah I I I guess I was
maybe drawn to her a bit more just
because of how like strange her vibe
always was she almost reminded me of the
little sister from hereditary but like
way less
you know sort of intentionally like oh
this is a strange character um but I
don't know I I can't disagree with you
watching all the West Wing yeah it was
great u i mean her whole role is TV but
I guess I kind of only this Aon soring
episodes I was like okay this is a
little too self-aware for my taste right
now yeah it's one of those things where
I'm like I don't necessarily put it
Beyond a character like this to have
that level of observation or detail or
digging to her interests or
whatever uh but but that's a very
writerly thing is to to name check and
just because you have Julia Roberts
being like you watch West Wing suddenly
makes that believable I guess um Ruth
lamp shading a little bit Yeah Ruth I
liked Ruth I thought Ruth I mean Ruth
has to occupy the in between space
between the young kids and the adult
adults and uh and I liked the inter I
mean I liked her kind of vibe because
she is the most
uh the most contrast from everybody else
and I think that her presence does
interesting things for all the different
characters and yeah like I I like they
should have ridden her to be more
seductive that would have been more
cliche so you could have been more
tempting to Ethan Hawk's character yeah
yeah we can turn this into knock knock
all of a sudden yeah I don't know like I
like that they flirted with that stuff
and didn't go there I like that she's
like yeah he's not that guy like he
wanted to but he's not that guy uh I
liked things like that and I thought the
interplay between her and her father
it's like even though they are presented
as a unit and you know there is a very
Us and Them between you know the two
pairs at first us or them damn Coral uh
but I thought that their tension between
each other was also a nice detail like a
microcosm because of course he's going
to try and be managing her expectations
but also she's super sharp not very
complacent not likely to be the kind to
just accept whatever ever Comfort is
being sold th% and I mean you know in
terms of all the characters even though
mersel Lai seems to have the most
concrete actionable knowledge of all of
our main characters she does seem to be
the one with like the most pragmatic
attitude oh for sure um and I thought
her performance was uh was quite good
too so I don't know I I like that
character I liked her too I liked her
too um everyone was really good I
thought the direction for for this was
Sol I actually really appreciated how we
would see actual outside world stuff
instead of just only keep like I I like
the stories where they just keep it
contained in the house don't get me
wrong like I I'm a sucker for that and
there's there's one part of me that's
like o I would have liked to have seen
that version yeah um but uh as it stands
I do think that this version that we got
is pretty compelling and I like the
glimpses we would get when they would be
like on the beach or when they would be
on the road and the tesas are crashing
or when they see the outside world uh
New York New York City uh being
destroyed feel convincingly cut off from
everything yeah yeah what's this movie
called again Leave the World Behind
Leave the World Behind sorry guys got to
prep some footage of simultaneously
while talking cuz time crunch oh we got
Kevin Bacon too Kevin Bacon I think um I
think as Kevin Bacon has gotten I I
wasn't a big fan of Kevin Bacon when I
was a kid okay but when he's got as he's
gotten older I have really grown to like
like the older Kevin Bacon performances
a lot the grizzled Kevin Bacon World
weathered Kevin Bacon is is a very good
bacon I really like I mean I've always
I've always kind of like that's a lie
I've always liked Kevin Bacon but I've
never but I've especially liked him as
he's gotten older yeah I've been way
more drawn to his like older man
performances yeah no because he brings a
good amount of like presence and and and
yeah he can show up and and it it feels
like effortless but also like he showed
up and here you know it's like you see
him in that one shot and the movie was
compelling enough that I forgot about
him for a long time and even though he's
only in a brief sequence you know
meaningfully uh I thought yeah he still
showed up and really kind of you know
fully committed to the kind of character
who he is and it's another aspect of the
movie that is certainly playing on and I
like that this movie played on and used
but didn't get lost
in not get lost in but I don't I think
it's it's appropriate the way the movie
used the sort of appearances and the
suspicion based on appearances you see
this guy and you're like okay of course
this is the guy who would be prepared
for all of this and of course for the
two of us the the yepy city guy and you
know person of color out here on your
American flag doorstep you know maybe
there's some precariousness to this
situation and uh it's all together
different feeling than you know when
they have the first meeting with you
know Julie Roberts and Ethan Hawk on the
porch um but yeah it's like without it
manages to encapsulate a lot of the
fears and paranoia people have some that
are Primal and you know everybody has
and some that are more societal and some
that are based on yeah like cultural
reservations and prejudices and what
notot yeah I thought it was great and I
think the dire so I think the direction
overall was excellent um I think there's
a lot of like really wonderfully shot
sequences with um some distorted angles
and um some beautiful symmetry rout and
they managed to make and when they
wanted to they have to make play scene
movies feel very like cinematic and they
did yeah and and I think too when they
did do sequences that uh were like out
on the road or whatever on the beach
they weren't like overshooting their
load like it felt very much like oh no
they they know what they're doing and
this is really composed um music I
thought was excellent all the hearkening
back to like old school types of horror
again I kept getting like Twilight Z own
flares from from it uh really enjoyed
that sound design flourish they kept
going for oh yeah sound design uh was
great too yeah um now I guess and the
the needle drops were were nicely
contrasted for the most part now I guess
the one thing left to talk about is did
you like the movie I did I did it's it's
a movie I'm going to keep thinking about
it it's a movie that I can you give me
that hard drive certainly uh it's eced
enjoyed in an immediate sense like I I
love the kind of movie that makes you
sit there and makes you sort of Wonder
and puts you in the paranoia and it
feels like some big conspiracy is going
down and it's it's kind of neat to me
that a poit what is essentially a
political thriller about a terrorist
attack or ostensibly is that they cut to
the moon at one point could be aliens
who knows uh but you know it's almost
like a political thriller without is
interesting did you did get the sense of
like is it an alien invasion yeah and
it's fun cuz in that way it feels feels
like you're watching yeah an Apocalypse
movie or maybe an alien invasion movie
or maybe some weird the happening or
whatever the house knock at the cabin
ended up being or something The Cabin in
the Woods yeah at the last house in the
cabin you didn't see that movie did no I
haven't but it's it's it's very I mean
that one's more I don't want that one's
more religious based um sure but but but
at least from the trailer that sort of
like something is coming and there's
we're isolated and paranoid and this
will be kind of like a play maybe th% uh
yeah so I I love that kind of a Vibe and
I like that this movie was able to kind
of keep you guessing as to like what
version of that are we watching I
thought it was appropriate where they
landed to give you pretty much the idea
without fully confirming the idea as
we've sat here and talked about it it's
sort of uh uh uh calcifying in a pretty
agreeable way with me like initially the
way where it ends I was like oh it would
be such a meme if they end it right here
but also in thinking about it I'm like
where else would I have ended this
because it's it it ends off in a way
where part of you is like well this
could easily keep going you know but I
think at least tonally right now I kind
of feel satisfied with what it is I
don't know exactly how great I would say
this is compared to what its aspirations
are but I don't think it's falling very
far short of its aspirations and I think
it's at least right now I thought it was
pretty good I'm going to
see okay uh I haven't seen the audience
score yet okay right now it's got a 75%
on uh Rotten Tomatoes I haven't seen the
audience score okay uh I just want to
get my opinion before it's influenced by
the audience score then I got to change
my entire point of view you update it
for the the crowd um but before we do
that John um here I'm creating this
little fold what did you think of
Obama's
producing I think he's trying to uh you
know have another career post presidency
yeah he's just got nothing now he's just
out here hustling trying to get a
buck uh can you put this in there yes of
course I do think it's fun and Charming
that this is what they chose to produce
uh sure I think they produce other stuff
um but you know I think it speaks a
little bit I I think it it makes it puts
it in a certain kind of lens Obama is
secretly telling us what to look out for
in terms of apocalpse I'm giving you
government secrets in this movie guys ex
I learned this this is text keep this
close and learn from it uh I I like I
did like the movie I I enjoyed it and um
I was really into it like the first hour
and 15 hour 20 minute Mark um and and I
kind of did you know sort of reveal
already like where movie started slowly
losing me a bit was when it does get
bogg down more in the like everything
stays strong like solid Direction uh and
the acting just remains phenomenal the
acting really I think helps save a lot
of that last hour for me um and while I
like the plot while I like the plot and
everything they're commentating on and
and and stuff and and sometimes the
writing it's weird this movie is one of
those things where and it's all open to
interpretation it doesn't ever it's it's
a a ver it borders on becoming so
expositional about what its point is yes
and then it also simultaneously leaves
you with it didn't quite tell you what
the point of the movie it didn't quite
leave you with the answer like I it it
weirdly leaves you in this terrain of
exposition heavy and ambiguity like at
the same time and normally you don't get
both and and and it kind of leaves you
with both it it definitely is one of
those movies that is is doing a big
contrast of like here's the plot stuff
and we're not going to spoon feed you
the actual story stuff like yeah and I
and I think that um I I could have used
a little bit more character driven
narrative and not not lose sight of that
basically as where it kind of seemed
like it wanted to talk more about its
ideas and then it would remind itself
the storytelling maybe it's like it in
the book I don't really give a [__]
we're talking about the movie all right
um that it would remind itself like we
got to be a little bit about the
characters and the intensity of what's
happened to the characters uh like
everything with like Maha Ali going to
the beach and all that and the
suspicions and then can they trust each
other and should they go should the you
know Julie Roberts and Ethan Hawk family
should they leave that was all so
gripping to me whilst doing the
commentary of what the hell's going on
in the outside world like I was really
enjoying that and and then when it it it
kind of brought it back around to the
scene with Kevin Bacon at the end of
like that immediacy and I was going like
I don't want M Le to die right now and
nor do want Ethan Hawk to die I don't
want anyone to get shot right now yeah
totally like I hope none of these guys
get killed yeah um and it's not like I
ever stopped caring during the film but
I did start to feel its runtime at a
certain point yeah because I wasn't as
invested in the character narrative and
I was finding it be more about what it
wants to talk
about than it does want to tell it
through the lens of the characters and
and and I and that's the one thing about
its focus that I wish it it honed in on
a little bit more sure so overall I I
really did like it like I think there's
a lot of craftsmanship to it that I
really enjoyed and you know for a stream
for in a day and age where where Netflix
dumps like a billion originals and and
and whatever uh I could see why this one
stood out why this one became a
conversation uh not only because of what
it's conversing with this audience about
but because of its caliber of film
making that it does you know and like
there is some real film making to this I
could have seen this as a theater
experience you know uh it doesn't feel
like made for TV or made directly for
stream like I could have seen this as a
theater going exper I think they I think
if it was the theater they probably
would have wanted a more concrete ending
they probably would have wanted
something that lays it out a little bit
better for its audience CU I could see a
scenario where some people feel like
it's abrupt the way it ends M where
where you were able to cuz I didn't I
actually didn't think it was going to
end when it ended yeah whereas you were
here going please let it end now ple and
it did and you were satisfied and for me
I didn't even get an inkling that it was
gonna end right there sure and I bet a
lot of people might not because because
you watch as like a bunch of got a low
ass audience
score that is really that is really low
Holy balls that is a low audience score
cuz you do watch a bunch of things that
are Loosely together like really kind of
scatter and then the movie ends it's
like they're all separated and they're
all seems like most people are pretty
upset cu the ending I bet cuz you get
this quick 5 Seconds of scrolling cuz
you reach this Crescendo with all the
deer and you're like wow where you and
and and something happened with the son
I guess he just did have lime dis like a
lime disease fast acting teeth falling
like like yeah you have these crescendos
of like they've run off into the woods
and they have this thing with the deer
and she's looking off at the beach and
the explosions happening and then Ethan
Hawk and MERS they're all down the road
and there was Kevin B and the girl she's
in the Panic Room and uh and and yeah it
ends at a point where Everything feels I
think innately kind of like you're in
the middle of something you know and uh
and yeah I think it's a thematic end
point that at least again to me right
now I I'm not 100% clicked in on but I'm
like yeah I I appreciate the The Quirk
of this choice but I can also absolutely
see people hating that because it it
gets you to that point where you're like
the only real Direction you have is when
Ethan Hawk and Marshall Ali are leaving
Kevin Bacon and they're like well I
guess we're just going to go back and we
got the medicine but the rest is all
like you know they're they're shouting
still trying to find Rose and Rose is
off doing her own thing and like yeah I
can it just all it all feels like a
bunch of big things presented and then
it's and then it's immediately done you
know yeah yeah I because I do think that
sometimes the I do feel like sometimes
the dialogue
overall while again like so much goes to
the the directors especially I mean the
actors especially and then occasionally
certain Choice with the directors uh
with the direction like like um when
like when Mah Ali is first giving this
the Spiel spiel about government agent
defense person and not saying who it is
yeah and then there's this little moment
where he like put puts his hand on her
to stop her from getting her drink and
he gets a little more serious and the
camera Clos I'm like okay that was a
good way to make that more interesting
yeah um cuz sometimes it feels like
they're it could be easy for some
moments when I pull out to go this kind
of feels like rambling pretentiousness
sure sure sure sure but I didn't ever
fully get there uh with any with any
moment even though at times that's what
I meant by how it would ride this line
where I feel like I'm getting so told
what this movie is about and then going
what is this movie about exactly yeah
yeah totally I get you cuz yeah it's
like you have to look at everything and
assume that most everything we were
being given or shown is important
somehow and I didn't think we needed the
like as much as I felt like Kevin Bacon
played that role and this is coming from
a from a man who identifies as liberal
or right I'm tell you this a guy who
identifies as liberal and and as funny
as I thought the moment was I thought it
was really funny um oh God the Korean or
whates yeah as much because this movie
is produced by Obama yeah um and
Hollywood is full of a bunch of leftists
you know that's right Bry I think that
you could have Sav yourself a lot of
when already a lot of this is very much
like leftist Scare Tactics or whatever
the [__] you want to call it right as
much as it's already there and so much
of the sentiment we obviously agree with
right I think cutting that out probably
would have helped the movie
points get across a little bit because
then it's especially for that to be so
close to the end of the film yeah that
does kind of cloud a lot of I'm like
because you don't need to
like if if this movie wants to be about
its messages if this movie wants to be
about its commentary yeah to some extent
right and like I think doing something
that specifically obviously is going
against you know like your your your
typical right-wing
personality um which I think was in the
form of Kevin Bacon at Le that's the way
I saw it big American flag or like the
Korean or tiny you
know [__] all sorted out yeah it's meant
to appear a certain way at face value
yeah yeah yeah so uh and I mean I I
think having that line excised probably
would have saved a little bit of
blowback perhaps yeah I'm curious cuz I
mean you know maybe I'm read more into
it than I need to I I personally just
feel that way I'm I am I don't know I'd
be curious to hear people's thoughts I
mean I think it does draw uh the main I
mean Julia Roberts and Ethan Hawk I feel
like are drawn as kind of a a yepy
neoliberal couple in a way that def
isn't overt as it is in like a get out
but like in a way that is clearly
commenting on them as people and and hey
even though they might appear you know
like this you know uh both beautiful and
also you know like uh I don't know they
they they get to the dysfunction of
their family later but you know they
appear as like you know a hip and with
it couple and he is very open and
accepting of things and and and all that
and and yeah they're not really all that
they want to sell you that they are uh
and then yeah you have Kevin Bacon who's
like a much more bold-faced sort of yeah
it's just a thing you would expect from
a character like that and so the one is
more subtle and the other is not yeah
because you have like Julia Roberts who
was pretty much admitting to like yeah I
had subconscious racism definitely
factoring in when I first met you like
she's her character is admitting to that
and the whole I hate people in general
you know I hate people in general or
even like I I could see the
Spanish-speaking Woman as a fear of the
unknown again with you know um yeah like
I I people coming into our country all
people but when I have to deal with them
I don't know what to do and I don't feel
like we are as the same as I would say
in poite conversation or whatever yeah
yeah and you know again to hammer in
that point of the movie of we aren't
really doing enough yeah and we can say
a lot and we could think we're
contributing but we're really not yeah
and there's so much we do every day that
is kind of meaningless and performative
and all that stuff yeah I think well
when you when you get to that whole
thing at the end with Kevin Bacon's
character which is those little couple
lines uh it's like yeah a little a
little much it is a little I thought it
was really fun I like the delivery
intentionally funny like I I thought
delivery was so good know yeah um but I
I do think that you you're already like
pushing the
boundaries your political point of views
here this movie is very political it's
extremely political yeah and it's not
and and it's not like without that beat
you wouldn't be able to communicate the
idea that the leaflets that Ethan Hawk
finds you know being you could still
establish that the same thing happened
with leaflets printed in Korean or
Chinese or whatever uh and that it's all
part of a misinformation scheme without
that little character you know Nick of
like oh yeah and he doesn't care what
the difference is sure sure you know at
first he seems so sure it's Korea and
the second someone's like are you sure
he's like well I don't know it could be
anything which again I I guess I'm I'm
torn because it is funny and it's like a
real thing and it serves the moment in
that initially you think again oh this
guy must know and then it's like well he
doesn't really no he just has like a
vague piece of context which is about as
good as you're going to get yeah but
yeah I mean at the same time it is one
of the more uh directly caricaturist is
elements of the characterization here
yeah even though he's the one who's a
survival one he was the one who had was
ahead of the curb here and he helps out
I mean he does eventually take the money
and give them the kill even though but
and I just think oh but then taking a
jab at that uh kind of negates like like
you're already painted this guy already
like not the greatest light yeah you
don't need to do like that additional
stuff because we already know what's
better about Ethan Hawk and mshel Ali
being able to team up where clearly this
guy's not going to be willing to team up
with y'all like the contrast will be
there whether we have that yeah beat or
not yeah man but um overall I liked it
overall I thought overall I really
enjoyed it and um it's a good time and
uh maybe one day I'll watch it again
maybe it's no bird B
s De maybe not a movie I could not
finish oh a movie I haven't even started
couldn't do it a I was like I'm going to
put it on and I was like 40 minutes in
was like I don't think I like I don't
think this mov is for me wow I'm excited
now I check it out I did not like the
there was so much about it I really
didn't like it really yeah just kiding
I'm bored with it oh I have so many
questions now as the movie we'll leave
you with um I think I don't know stop 40
minutes in definitely question finish it
couldn't stand characters man couldn't
stand it that's fair that's fair like
that felt like a streaming movie to me
for sure this felt way more above that
okay okay did it feel uh even though I
know people like Bird Box way more than
like this movie I was going to say did
that movie feel very high on its
messaging did it feel very like we're
doing profound [__] over here in the
bird bu I don't recall thinking that I
just remember really not finding the
characters believable and and to me it
was the characters I just didn't like
the characters okay good to know and I
didn't think the good actors um were
enough to elevate it or help me see past
how terrible the characters were Sandy
didn't save the movie I don't remember
who that is Sandra Bullock oh yes the
lead you did not save it for me all
right but what do you guys think they'll
Leave the World Behind leave your
thoughts down below appreciate y'all
being here um be sure to subscribe tell
us who you're voting for in the comments
um um keep politics out of this video
but put it in the comments yeah keep
your politics out of who's your 2024
vote in comeing this election year Woo
which debate are you looking forward to
the most oh yeah in your specific state
you live
in
um what Third Party candidate will you
cast a vote for in order to ensure that
your vote doesn't really sway anyway if
you're the actual election if you're not
part of America what do you think about
America leave your thoughts down Below
in the comments what have you think
thought about a recent
presidency and the one before that and
the one before that leave it all down in
the comments below and whoever replies
to you make sure to reply back to them
and keep that conversation going yeah
whatever it takes don't even you don't
even have to listen to each other just
keep spouting your own point of view and
uh fill that comment box I think as long
as you guys keep trying to convince each
other that you're the right one 100%
right by the way one of you is bound to
be
not wasting their
time shot it could be
you is the patri of the day shout
out all right John pick a name
uh pandemic Jones pandemic Jones my
friend merry Christmas you know what
Santa's giving you this year well what
do we know about pandemic JS what do we
know about he's giving you an
inoculation what an inoculate
vaccination that's exactly what I was
going to say except not with such fancy
terminology oh sorry yeah vaccines
inoculate you to various diseases and or
P high brow vernacular for my brain what
the hell was that that's Ebon or Scrooge
of me let me bring it down to the the
street level that's right you're getting
the jab this year my friend pandemic and
you know what this one's going to
protect you against more than just what
everyone else is protected against
you're going to get V you're going to
get protected against you know um
people's incompetence you're going to
get protected against uh herpes you're
going to get protected against uh it's
like paying too much for stuff at the
grocery or any other store it's a coupon
really is what you're getting and you're
also going to get protected against
being taken advantage of at card
mechanics just whenever I'm about to
finally insert you just go andert you're
going to be protected against
interruptions is what I hope you get
protected against
Mr what you say
inoculation it
worked did it yes it did guess I
remember the word now I didn't interrupt
you then it's my new favorite word yeah
get inoculated baby Merry Christmas PJ
hope s or Jesus or somebody gives you
something special this year the
Jab